[Musik]
apa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wieder
ich träume von
doch eben
ein traum
[Musik]
menschen so hennig
roster getrieben
und darf einmal sagt sie
si
sh
so stand sie vor 17 jahren
blondes haar
wie wenig zu 17 jahre
so stand sie vor 17 jahren
plant deshalb
wie viel zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
messi messi messi
[Musik]
für dichtung
denn
cherry cherry unsere linie
war
so schön
mehr
die
sei nicht traurig muss sich auch von dir
[Musik]
die
adieu
deine bringen
so wie
unser traum
da hin
mehr
rheine
auch das hat so
ich schaue nach vorn
nicht zurück
zwingen kann
man kann
denn kein mehr
die welt
den link
überall ein
nur die
wie kann so sagen
so seien
so sehr
[Musik]
merci merci merci
für die sturm
bei cherry
cherry unsere link
so schön
mehr
[Musik]
und nach dem abendessen sagte hier lass
mich noch eben zigaretten holen gehen
sie rief ihn nach nimm dir die schlüssel
mit ich werde inzwischen nach der
kleinen sehen
er zuckte dir zu ging sturm hinaus ins
neon helles treppenhaus es noch nach
mona wachs
spießig karl i
auf der treppe dachte
wenn das jetzt
[Musik]
ich musste einfach gehen
alle 2
[Musik]
alle zeit ich war noch niemals in new
york
ich war noch niemals auf arbeit gegen
san francisco
[Musik]
new york
nein
einmal verrückt sein
aus allen
[Musik]
dann ist steckte er die zigaretten ein
und ging wie selbstverständlich heim
durchs treppenhaus mit bohnerwachs und
spießigkeit
die frau rief
man wo bleibst du die sts
geht gleich los sie fragte
nein
was soll schon
was soll schon sein
ich war noch niemals in
ja
ich war noch die basis auf arbeit
gegen die
francisco in see
[Musik]
als kind
ja baby war
richtig frei einmal verrückt sein und
aus allen zwängen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ihr werdet euch noch wundern wenn ich
rentner bin
sobald der stress vorbei ist dann leicht
klebrig
[Musik]
jedes
natürlich äußerst lässig das ist mir
noch nie
und sie in meine bauverein und preis
[Musik]
und sehe mich die leute entrüstet
anstrengen
ich sehe dass wir zuerst mit 66 jahren
selbst verschuldet mit 66 jahren er hat
man spaß daran mit 66
ist noch lange nicht schluss
[Musik]
kaufe mir ein motorrad und eine mail
adresse
er ist mit 100 mbit s
[Musik]
ich singe im stammwerk lieder dass jeder
nur so staunen
spiele zu
sauber
[Musik]
mit den anderen
ein bisschen mehr zahlen
so 60 jahre sind für besondere mit 66
jahren da hat man spaß daran mit zu
setzen
er ist noch lange nicht schluss
[Musik]
treffen
täglich um 14 8 38 euro
[Musik]
in der konditorei h
blasen zum sturm
empfehlen
schon auf st
auch früchte als anders kirchen
aber bitte mit sahne
[Musik]
die schwarzen und schmerzen dann holen
sie sich
[Musik]
mutter kennt
bienenstich
[Musik]
zu ostern
was geht nichts mehr rein
[Musik]
mit wohnen
beim 1
si
aber bitte mit sahne
[Musik]
[Applaus]